right thank you very much uh for the
opportunity to talk
it's quite nice uh to be able to talk
just after um ben actually
i barely lost
um
because i guess it was it was the fact
that he came out with his paper and also
these other guys sang and co that abby
was mentioning earlier came out with
their paper
earlier in the year
that uh kind of got me thinking about
the ident and theorem again so
again talk about uh
as gil said quantitative
aspects
of the identity
um
right
okay
so um
i perhaps would have said before so the
identity theorem is sort of the harmonic
analyst's name for one of the things
that ben talked about earlier
and um i'll um
i'll make that connection um
i was hoping to stop by if you like
explaining why we're interested in it
from a mathematician's perspective
um so i actually thought
in that regard a little bit um
about some of the basic things i suppose
we do in the
the undergraduate syllabus um
at the university and i wanted to start
with um projections
um
so um
projections are sort of at least
in this talk i want to think about
projections as
uh ways of of uh decomposing
uh things like groups or uh vector
spaces so
so if um
uh if g is
say finite
um
abelian group
then we can write
she is a direct sum
of
uh h directs
h direct some k
um
or then we call
uh
a
direct sum
decomposition
of g
if uh
h and k are subgroups of g
and
h and set k is just zero
i was a bit worried actually with these
boards
that uh
sort of stupidly when i saw gill start
that i was gonna have to write right at
the bottom
of course
i'm just going to do what gil did start
at my height and stop it
why it was concerning me
notable differences
and so um
oh
this relates
to projection
by
defining our projection
let's say pi
from g to g it takes
could you speak just a little bit
sure
so this relates to projections um
in this this way we can define a
projection associated with this direct
sub decomposition just takes h k to um
to h
okay
um
and for any direct sun decomposition you
can define a projection like this
and it has the property
and
uh
that uh
chi squared equals pi
and so if you have a homomorphism
pi
from g to itself
then you can also that is a projection
like this then you can also
define a direct sum decomposition
okay
and what you care about
direct some decompositions
to some extent because it's a way of
breaking up your group g
okay
and so you can also do this
with say a norm space
so
the projection
on x
is a
autism
pi from x to x
such that pi squared equals pi
let's say uh
finite dimensional
um
i'm not going to worry too much about
analysis in this talk
okay
um
but with normal spaces
we obviously also have a norm
um
and uh that norm in some sense gives you
a notion of
uh
the quality of your projection
uh
so
it's natural suppose this were for a
moment infinite dimensional it would be
natural not just to ask for this to be a
um
uh homomorphism of vector spaces but it
also be natural transfer to be
continuous
and then you could ask
um i mean that would be clearly the
correct thing to do
and then you can ask um
if you like how continuous and a measure
of how continuous is the size of the
norms for the quality of this uh
some rather nebulous sense
the quality of this
direct sum
decomposition
is measured
by the norm of pi it's just the operator
norm in this case
i might as well take it to be
um
right again that's a measure of if you
like how continuous this map pi is
okay
so there's a few
maybe i can really labor this even a
little bit more
and i could just consider a little
example to emphasize what i mean so if
say x is
r squared with um
the infinity norm
they're just the
the max in the usual cartesian
coordinates
and uh
e1 is just the vector one one
and e two is the vector one one plus
epsilon for some
tiny
epsilon then you could and we'll define
pi
from x to x
just as an example of a projection
just take
ah
so lambda one e one plus lambda two e
two
and map it to
well that's whatever
lambda one e one
okay
so there's
a uh e1 and e2 form a basis in the
linear algebra sense of r squared
and so
this is a sensible map it's well defined
it's nice and linear
but
it has a stupid little big norm right
so
clear map
it has a jolly big norm
right and that's that's because we chose
idiot basis right
so if i want to make up
um
if i want to look at say pi of
naught one
well
i guess i make naught one in this basis
by taking
it's on inverse copies of
e2 minus e1
so that's the unique way of making it
then
pi of
excuse me
pi of naught one
is whatever i have stone inverse e1
so
norm of pi is
at least somehow around epsilon inverse
that's a bad projection right it's sort
of a it's a projection that just is
reflecting the up this algebraic choice
of what's going on
um
so of course it's slightly
what one thing that this highlights
is the fact that
um
projections and uh
say closed subspaces or just subspaces
in the finite dimensional case
um
are not in some sense a one-to-one
correspondence right you can pick a
there are a range of projections you
could pick for a given substrate
um
basically because there are i give you a
basis for a subspace there's a range of
ways of completing
the uh the super space
so you could
you could nevertheless pick a best
projection pi right a projection pi with
minimal norm that would be a sort of
sensible thing to do
and um
if you do that you can still show that
um as the dimension increases
you can construct subspaces
in general say if x is l1
where there's no
highly continuous projections and this
just represents the fact that
uh you can't um
you know you can have subspaces where
the you can have spaces finite spaces
where the only complemented subspace is
finite dimension
or or co-finite-dimensional
right
but i want to convince you in some sense
that
this
this norm somehow measures the quality
of your projection so it's a natural
there are sort of two things to come out
of what i've said so far so one is
right it's a sensible thing if i give
you a space to try and decompose it into
smaller spaces
um that's the sort of basic thing we do
in maths and the other is that in some
sense we can measure the quality of this
decomposition
by the norm of the
projection operator to say the minimal
norm of a projection operator
corresponding to the decomposition
okay
those are the two things to remember
from
from that
um
maybe i should mention one other example
so of course if if you're hilbert space
so i mean
r squared is
perfectly reasonable hilbert's base we
could have stuck l2 on here this is
still a basis right it's not an
orthonormal basis so if you're in uh
hilbert space you can always pick your
projections to be nice orthogonal
projections if you just start with the
subspace
just by
i mean in the obvious way
so hilbert's base projections behave
particularly nicely and the norm of the
projection and hilbert's place is always
going to be one
um for what we're considering
okay
so the second uh
um
thing to mention is that uh
well one uh
way of uh understanding
let's say
finite ability in groups g
ah is through
uh representations
okay again i suppose i claim if you're a
mathematician you would like to
understand
groups
um and you could do so through
you could do so through their
representations
so
let's say so
for example we
might be interested
in
uh some representation rho so this is
just a
morphism
from g into
the l of x
where
x is some
finite dimensional norm space
so i'm using the norm here to stick a
topology on
okay
um
so a very natural one
maybe
down here so a natural example
is
if x is just l2 of g
and
rho is the regular representation
if it takes
f to the map
which maps f
excuse me it maps f to
uh
um
f of x minus y
uh so
this is the map row y it sends a
function f in l2 of g just to the
function translated around a little bit
right
so that's the usual thing and that maps
l2 to l2
um
and then it's just well known right then
that you
you sit down and you ask
uh
well you ultimately you try to
decompose
this representation this regular
representation into
uh irreducible um
some representations but we're just
going to a first step i mean we all know
what the answer is so
well
anyway the answer is well known
um
but we're just imagining just suppose
you you're just starting this game so
then you would
decomposing did i
yeah let's just call it row
uh
so we'd look we might look for
projection pi
now
the projection would be on the uh
the underlying space x right
so projection pi on
from l2 of g to l2 of g
and then you want it to be compatible
with representation right so you would
want
ah
to commute with representation
okay
so what i'm saying to you here is this
would be a natural
uh
a natural way of trying to split up this
representation of two subrepresentations
okay
and if you did that
and doing this
you could
whatever
talk about the quality of this
as measured
by pi
also in this case because it's on
hilbert space i told you earlier all the
all the projections on hilbert space you
could pick
they don't all have norm one but you can
because in actual fact we're interested
in
decomposing l2 of g into two parts not
the specific so we're interested in any
projection that decomposes l2 into two
parts not the specific projection
um
you can always pick a projection
corresponds to that subspace that
subspace decomposition which has normal
so it's all nicely behaved
and so this is a bit of this is a little
bit pointless
um
but i haven't just been wasting your
time
uh
so
a natural alternative space you could
consider
so
this is
less exciting
but uh
so alternatively
we could consider
uh
bro again algebraically the same
representation
but this time
into l1 of g okay so algebraically it's
doing exactly the same thing it's
it's trending
translating functions around
but analytically
it's going to be doing something
slightly different because you have a
different norm
okay
so um
so again
uh
uh
well
so just
so we i just want to slightly rain
everyone back in if some of this has
been a bit
uh
vague
so row here is just a regular
representation defined exactly like it
is over there on functions okay the only
thing that's different from what we're
doing over there is i've stuck a
different norm on the space okay see
anything so this time i've got
the l1
okay
so
we could decompose it as we did up here
or we could try
right
so then you have a slightly different
situation
so
um
this stuff by the way this is really
just all
uh
there's a book by rudin
which more or less
um
thanks i've been talking about so far
a furry analysis on uh
groups
so rudin uh
i guess gets his knickers in a bit of a
twist over some of the analysis but
since g is finite here we're not um
it's not a problem for us
um
so
uh
for them we sort of
well what i want to say is i don't want
to give the argument but it's not a
particularly difficult argument
so by uh
sort of basic arguments
i know that sounds a bit lame um
we get uh
so firstly that um
because of this
commuting with um a regular
representation you get the
uh
pi of f actually has the form
pi of f is f controlled with mu
for some measure of mu on g so this just
is some measure mu one g i mean g is
finite so it's
you know it's not particularly important
you could think of this as a function
with um
it's signed but a function where you
could just take some of the kind of
absolute values of the of the
values of mu
maybe since i haven't written down
convolution yet it would be helpful
so this is just that function
um
so and then secondly well since
i is a
projection
we get that
much involved with mu is mu
it's just that pi squared is pi
and thirdly
the operator norm of pi
will not surprise you to learn
norm of mu
okay
and the
uh the identity theorem as classically
stated concerns
measures mu in the
measure algebra m of g
that are idempotent
with bounded
norm
okay and the reason that they were
originally interested in this thought a
reason they were originally interested
in these things is that
once you understand
if you understand what they are then you
understand precisely how you could
decompose the ways in which you could
decompose this representation and in
particular that the representation
doesn't decompose in particularly
exciting
exciting fashion okay
so um
maybe i will rather than state with
classical identity theorems then i'll
state the quantitative identity theorem
i'm managing to keep my voice up for you
brilliant
uh
so this was something
uh
with uh pen
that we've worked on it's already been
stated i guess but uh
um
that uh
so let's say suppose
peter
um
ah
and
sorry it's a bit of fun
yeah okay so um
so we've got a function say that's
integer valued or if you like
minus one one i'll come back to why i've
written the integers up there in a
moment
but like ben had minus one one here and
it's sort of
it's the same for what we're going to do
where this norm is small so this is the
the uh
that quantity
is small then you can write f as a plus
minus
sum of indicator functions of cosets of
subgroups of the group g and there
aren't that many
okay um
this is sort of dual to this
okay so g here
is really
g hat here okay
uh
that you can sort of make sense right
we're looking at the l1 norm of the
fourier transform here and we're really
just looking at
the l1 norm if i hadn't that with
measures instead of functions
okay
um and then what i want to
talk about today is really
um
is
getting rid of one of these exponentials
so as we heard from that uh you know
they've been
uh
uh
many people later in the year have sort
of strengthened different applications
and aspects of this
uh in different directions
um
so this is somehow still returning to
the uh
the the classical problem
um
it is just in terms of what you should
expect to be true in this level of
generality if g is z for example
you can't get better than big o of m up
here
um
you could broaden
your idea of what a subgroup or
well because your idea of what a
subgroup is is fixed but
you could be more inclusive
about your notion of subgroup and you
could then hope to do better
um
but somehow
i don't know i believe there probably is
a fairly natural proof
that we'll give a big l of m here i
don't know what it is of course
um
somehow there is a natural theorem in
there that is limited by obstacles that
they don't exist over
uh say groups well say over f2 to the n
g is f2 to the end those obstacles don't
exist but somehow they exist in zed and
so there's a class of proofs that would
only
that don't see the difference between
different types of say finite ability
and group and
i suspect within that class of proofs
there's one that gives a bigger m here
what do you believe
okay
um
yeah
basically because arithmetic
progressions exist
long ago progressions exist
so groups where they don't exist
like f2 to the n
um
you hope to do better
okay
um
i'm not going to i sort of feel
timing-wise it wouldn't be ideal i'm not
going to sort of
labor the connection but this
the reason mathematically you might care
about this is because this characterizes
these measures mu
in a not completely unnatural way and
therefore
tells you how this representation
decomposes and
i mean yeah that's a thing you could do
good okay um
so uh
sorry
in your statement
yeah that's yeah g is for example a
finite ability group
you can um
barring this part you can
make it non-appealing
and you can also stick some topology on
and spend some time
mucking around with analysis
well
yeah so that's good let's
so yeah so uh
or or zed if you're talking about finite
sets but yeah so let's say
said mod pz
it's p sum large prime
so what this effectively tells you is
that either um
either f is uh
and so if you think of m as bounded p
tending to infinity but large prime then
it tells you that either
f is almost always minus one or almost
always one
right
because
there's only one or whatever there's
only one big sub group so yeah
um and that's you see in that situation
where the sort of
if i took a an arithmetic progression of
length p over two for example
then so say
ah
the indicator function of p here
progression of length
you have a two
then
the
that is
log p
in that situation that's why i expect
big o of m here if you sort of go back
because somehow how many
how many cosets of subgroups do i need
well
um
you know the only there are only two
subgroups
the the big one and the little one
and
you know you either use the big one or
you don't but it converts into sort of
the same thing but then you have to get
lots of copies of the little one
yeah so the size of the group you want
10 to infinity but so yes for example
z mod 2 z
to the end thinking of
peers in some sense being about the same
as two to the n
yes yeah so it could be i think that's
what ben was saying as well anyway
that was
um
yeah it could
it could be that though
um or at least i mean
i don't know of any examples that
yeah maybe it's that
um
yeah yes so but what i was trying to
sort of say earlier been you know
rather feebly
was somehow
yes i i guess so that would be nice and
it'll be really you know i suppose
potentially useful result but
so i guess this with a big o of m i
guess there is some natural proof of
that and it probably works over the
class of let's say finite appealing
groups and it would have some property
where it doesn't really see the
difference between
so we we know sort of in practice there
are lots of differences between this and
this but actually um articulating
exactly what they are in a way that's
useful for proofs
isn't
it's not easy for me anyway
maybe other people do that better
um but yes expressing the fact that you
have no
long arithmetic progressions in this for
example
if um is integer value instead of
boolean then the conclusion that sigma
is
also going to be
integer values
no because this is so rubbish
i could just i can i'm not making them
distinct so i can just stack them up so
the l infinity of f is bounded by the um
so this is a
fact
if i normalize it correctly so that will
tell you
normalize it so that that's true
and
uh and then
so i can just sort of cheat but it's
it's actually it's good you raise that
some
uh
excellent um
right
okay
uh so
with um
with ben
green
i think almost every instance of ben so
far has been bent
this is an instance of penguin
uh
okay
in in this paper
excuse me we had the following strategy
so
let's say suppose um
this is an example f is the indicator
function of some set
then uh
we want to uh
find some subgroup v
um
and put
and decompose f like this
so let me say what all these things are
so mu v
this is just the probability measure
supported on v
i said this is
it's obviously true
see daisy
uh this is obviously trivially true
um
um what we want is
so when you take the fourier transform
of these the fourier transform of this
little guy
is supported on
uh
the complement of the perp
okay and the fourier transform of this
guy is fortunate on v purp
so the point is doesn't matter if you
know what v purp is or not all you need
to know is that they have disjoint
fourier support okay
um
and so what you have happen is
uh
the l
the l1 norm of this
this must be the l1 norm of the furrow
transform of this guy on the left
is equal to
uh
the sum of these two things
and so
part of the plan will be
well suppose suppose we were really
lucky
and also this guy here so this guy's
just the average value of a over cosets
of v that's that's what it evaluates to
be
suppose this guy we're always either
naught or one okay it's quite unlikely
but suppose that we really we got that
okay
then this guy would also be a
um
this guy would be the indica function of
a set and this guy would be the
indicator function of a set
and suppose those sets were non-empty
then by using the inequality luka
just mention or you know that this thing
then you'd have that
each of these are sort of bigger than
zero so maybe at least one so you have a
situation where
the l1 norm of each of these parts is
smaller than val one norm of the thing
you started with okay so you would have
you would have all those things lined up
in some lovely way
you would have found a nice way of
decomposing
your function you could hope to run an
inductive argument within this framework
okay super
so
none of that works exactly but all of it
works roughly
so in particular this guy's not going to
take the values 001
but you can force him to take values
very close to nortal one and you can
take the other arguments we want to talk
about
and make them kind of stable under some
small infinity perturbation
um
and
yes right and you could so so you make
this sort of
so we make her
so to make this work
we
expand our class
to consider
what you could call epsilon almost
integer valued functions
some
it just means that they're within
epsilon being some integer value so it's
the usual thing of if you have a bigger
it's easier to induct over a bigger
class
sometimes
um
because although you've got more stuff
you've got to throw
you've got a bigger target to hit
so
sometimes that's bonus and it's here
so
the key problem the reason that
uh with ben
green
uh
we ended up with doubly exponential
bounds is
when you do this
expansion
so suppose now
one a with some func is not
not one value that's
epsilon close to being normal and valued
then this guy here
this could actually be twice as bad
right it could be somehow that this is
within epsilon of
being not one valued
and this is with an epsilon of being not
one value but somehow they're lined up
in for some points they're lined up in
the wrong way so somehow every time you
run
you would run this sort of inductive
step you'd split into things that were
twice as bad in that almost integer
valuedness
as
you started with okay
so
how bad would that get well
if everything i told you were to go
through
you you would expect to have to run this
decomposition at least say
m times or something like that
okay because by that time you would then
have got down to things which all had
uh algebra norms called the algebra
this l1 norm of the fury transform one
so
um
i suppose by any stroke good fortune i
started late
ah brilliant do you know
how late
you have some we have flexibility okay
right
um
yeah so
so we'd be the whole this whole scheme
in some sense you'd hope to run you'd
expect to run about 11 times
so you're expecting your epsilon
parameter to be sort of hit by roughly a
2 to the m
okay
so
uh
that's something to sort of remember so
we will need
not as
small as
about 2 to the m okay the point is it's
exponential in m
roughly you know i don't know
let's put a big o here
okay
so i'm going to come back to that
because that's this somehow is the big
the
hiccup and there are two reasons that
it's a haircut
and um
both gone away
um
okay
so now
we need uh
what one trivial way of doing this
decomposition would somehow be to pick v
to be some space totally unrelated to a
and then this guy would sort of flat
line a lot of the time he'd be very
small suppose a is really sparse then
he'd be really really small
and this would sort of be
oh this would be epsilon almost interval
but actually the problem you'd have
would be that this guy would also be
very small so your induction wouldn't
work so
you genuinely need
this to take kind of large values
okay
and so
the first thing you
you do is you want to find
some subgroup v that correlates with
a
and that's something there's a theorem
for that foreign
so uh let me just
because i want to get to how we deal
with this so let me just this will be a
little bit quick
so
uh
it turns out by sort of
it's unusual holder degree pokery
uh
this is true where this is something
called the additive energy
and then there's a theorem
uh
balloon ready gowers fryman
which says
that if
that's the case
then there's some subgrouping v of g
such that
this guy is large
and
hopefully i haven't
occasionally it's possible to state this
in a way that's obviously trivial
yeah i think that's good
okay
um
i don't want to emphasize too much about
this
because of uh
work of various people things like
krutsy sask and
thomas jones
this turns out to be a relatively good
bound
what it's saying overhaul it somehow if
you have small algebra norm
so this part is easy
and this part i guess is hard
uh if you have small algebra norm
then you can find some
subgroup
so i'm going to say that yep sub group v
of g
such that uh a has large density on this
subgroup and the subgroup is not too
small okay and this this turns out to be
pretty big for that purpose
this was one of the pl so this
when
ben and i wrote this paper
this was a
polynomial in m
and that was one of the ways in which we
lost an extra exponential
okay i don't i don't want to dwell on
this too much
because this is not
that's just plugging in the fact that we
have better bounds now
um
yeah yeah so right
um
now
um
so now the other thing we want to do is
um
uh
well
okay let me give you a little bit of
philosophy again
so
this
this kind of bound um
if you if group if the group g were
had some nice topology this would tell
you that f was uniformly continuous it's
just a uniform limit of continuous
functions it's continued sorry it's
continuous
okay
and so somehow intuitively incidentally
you see you have a you have a function a
continuous function taking discrete
values so you expect the level sets to
be open and closed
in a topological group the obvious
things that are open and closed are
subgroup are open subgroups
because the complement of an open
subgroup is a union of cosets of that
subgroup
and
a union of open sets a coset of an open
set is open and a union of open sets is
open so that
all open subgroups are also closed
and so and you can obviously create open
closed open and closed sets by unioning
and intersecting finitely open and
closed sets so you sort of intuitively
expect the fact that
this means continuous continuous
interdiscrete means level sets are open
and closed
it turns out basically the only way to
create open and closed sets in this
context
is um from subgroups that's sort of some
it's not a proof of anything it's just
kind of in your heart what's going on
um
so the idea then is in some sense one a
is a bit continuous and you can
introduce a sort of quantitative
continuity
so let me state a
a thing
and then tell you what it means
so this is really the only new content
so suppose that f
from g to c
uh
has so again we just got this nice
one was m
p is some parameter for an lp norm
bigger than two and epsilon
uh is some sort of measure of how
continuous this guy is
uh
well i would like to do it relative to
this subspace v but i'm not going to
bother for a minute
so then there exists
v prime a sub group of g such that
and
so this
tells you the co-dimension of v prime is
small it's linear in p is the point okay
and just polynomial and epsilon inverse
at m
and this is some kind of notion of
continuity
that i
this tells you that f doesn't vary much
from the average of f over cosets of v
prime
in lp norm
and the point we we were previously
using p equals 2.
the problem then is you need to make
this
this epsilon needs to be exponentially
small
okay
if you're allowed to use p
varying
then you can show that the
um because this is the average value of
this that in actual fact this bootstraps
epsilon about one over m
to being epsilon exponentially small in
p
and so p
is this linear parameter just
has to depend then only on m
okay
so you can see
so you get a linear dependence on p here
by chang's theorem or rudin's inequality
or backness inequality or whatever you
wanna
you know
um
there's a whole bunch of things that are
the same thing really
uh
well i'm almost finished i'm sorry
because
i'm i do
yeah
um
uh
and so let me just show you the
the thing i said about being small
so this is somehow the way you save the
other exponential by the fact that p
you uh p depends is just
larger than m not large
not it's just sort of linear in m not
exponential in m
so the point here is suppose
i suppose you know
first we just have a situation suppose a
and g
has density
alpha and you know that
this is the case so this is roughly
this specialized f is the indicator
function of a set and um restrict it to
one atom
okay
i suppose you know this is the case and
let's say alpha is less than a half
okay well then
measure of the set of x
such that
it's large
uh
let's take
and you have
this and so
but this here
uh
just
the measure of the set hey basically if
i've chosen my parameters sensibly
alpha a bit smaller
so alpha which is equal to the measure
of this at a is less than four epsilon
to the p
so the point is alpha being small gets
bootstrapped by this to alpha being
exponentially small
and making alpha exponentially small in
p
is
less expensive
okay
and you need to make
alpha or epsilon is over here
exponentially small
because of this thing i mentioned before
okay so two places we lost
uh before
one of them was in this part here
and the other one was in this part here
i know i've rushed that last bit
hopefully you understood the first part
and maybe some people are more familiar
with it understood the last part but i
think i'll stop there
thank you
so this is the new
here which is
well
um four or four in fact but so e to the
m to the fourth
four plus one and before it was double
exponential
it's a different four from before
actually as well
and it's uh is this the tools already or
no it's a problem well i i
i don't know that it's not the truth but
um
but clearly it's not
i think it should be bigger of him
but maybe for what i was perhaps trying
to suggest earlier is maybe if g is um
f2 to the n for example
dumb questions
i'll find very beautifully here
uh mathematical structure
comparing several examples there and
earlier we heard many results there
but who would have guessed in advance
of the study of the fourier transform
would give some information about
complexity
i was really perplexed
that there would be a connection there
uh i mean that's all assaults but
who would have guessed in advance
to do that the uh decomposing the
regular representation over l2 is is
sort of exactly what the fourier
transform is so
um
you look for
a base the fourier transform is in the
unique in some sense change of basis
that simultaneously diagonalizes all the
operators induced by that representation
so um in in that sense maybe
i don't know whether that's something
you also kind of come to after the fact
but um so
you also i suppose at some stage have to
have the insight that
studying representations is a good thing
uh which obviously we kind of know it is
now but that was clearly
you know good idea
um
yeah i don't know so maybe that's a
little it's not a perfect answer
if you think part two on the left
independently do you expect the correct
dependency to be one over m i mean
yeah
in the correlation do you expect yeah
yeah in fact it is i'm just uh
oh one over i was hedging because
there's a two there and
yes you're right it's a well yeah
there's maybe there's some question
about the precise epsilons you have here
sorry the percent
just created epsilon
you couldn't have made sense of that
statement i just made
it's not the thing i
this
should be like a one minus eta over
m squared
and
whether it should or shouldn't be there
i don't know
oh
yeah maybe there'll be various questions
about whether they happen together but
say the m dependence i think has to be
at least linear for reasons of long
arithmetic progressions
episodes this has to be at least
epsomerized too for reasons of nouveau
sets
and this here has to be
here sort of just for reasons of mass
you can't squeeze enough mag
checking p is the easy one
um but whether they all maybe you could
first plus
it could be
pluses and yeah but but it's not it's
not horrifically wrong um and the reason
i i don't speak for ben i guess the
reason i was relatively convinced by
this sort of doubly exponential boundary
before was
well
yeah one reason but that another reason
here was somehow
well we're using p equals two you sort
of have to have this epsilon minus two
so
it
yeah somehow
again